françois rey terrière bonsoir l'éternel
comme vous le savez on paie 3 nous
recevons l'auteur donné c'est d'un
document d'un témoignage ce soir patrick
chesnais toujours en compagnie de rama
yade et de liane foly alors patrick
vous m'avez fait pleurer deux fois dans
ma vie la première fois c'est quand je
vous ai vu sur scène dans une pièce qui
s'appelait skylight je me suis tu allais
dans votre loge jeu j'étais en larmes
complètement l'un bouleversé et la
deuxième fois c'est quand j'ai lu le
livre que vous avez publié à la rentrée
qui s'appelle iv ou ferdinand journal
d'un père orphelin chez michel lafon
voilà alors le vendredi 13 octobre 2006
à 3h19 du matin votre fils ferdinand
meurt dans un accident de voiture porte
d'auteuil il a vingt ans après une
représentation de soleil noires d'été
comédiens et une soirée bien arrosée
un ami le raccompagne il à 1,68 gramme
d'alcool dans le sang y prend le périph
dans le mauvais sens et il percute une
voiture qui arrive en face les deux
conducteurs sont sortent pas ferdinand
perdit n'en est plus là et vous décidé
d'essayer de le faire vivre en écrivant
au jour le jour à partir de ce moment là
oui c'est une seconde naissance
j'ai été obligé de faire l'apprentissage
d'un nouveau monde dire qu'en fait à
partir du moment où ferdinand disparaît
vous vous recommencez à apprendre à
vivre dans un monde différent du
précédent oui enfin c'est à dire qu'il
ya effectivement il ya toujours eu ce
genre de catastrophes yahia avant et
après si je peux dire évidemment c'est
pas pareil c'est quand tu gagnes son
fils
c'était une façon de
de le faire vivre à quelques-uns de plus
oui le essayer de le prolonger n'ont pas
servi moi tout cas son existence d'une
manière puisqu'il est plus là
en parlant de lui en faisant des films
ce que j'ai fait le plein fils et puis
en écrivant ce bouquin qui était un
space 2 journal ait voulu parler
peut-être qui vous écoute vous n'en
savez rien en fait
alors c'est une grande question
parfois oui parfois j'avais l'impression
que peut-être ils pouvaient m'écouter
montant de qu'on pouvait bien longue et
en tout cas il me renvoyait des shing
je suis pas sûr vous lui dites que vous
l'aimez vous lui dit je t'aime mon grand
tu al'avantage d'être mort ça facilite
les aveux et on se rend compte en lisant
cette phrase que les gens qu'on aime
quand ils sont vivants on leur dit pas
assez qu'on les aime et la boue lui
avait dit quand il était vivant mais là
d'un seul coup évidemment ça c'est plus
facile parce que c'était pas bien de ne
sait pas très bien de dire toujours à
ses enfants qu'on les aime en tout cas
moi c'est pas c'est pas mon truc et une
fois qu'ils et puis là évidemment ça
prend des proportions 1 quand j'ai lu
votre bouquin j'ai appelé mon fils je
suis dit je t'aime
oui j'en reçois beaucoup de lettres de
doigt dessus je les appelais j je t'aime
tu la prunelle de mes yeux vu alors tu
aurais voulu que je sois un peu plus
marrant c'est une phrase extraordinaire
tu aurais voulu que je sois un peu plus
marrant je vais essayer de faire plus
rigolo mais bon c'est un sujet qui au
départ exclu comique quand même nom mais
ferme y en avait beaucoup d'humour on a
beaucoup rigolé ensemble
c'est pas un bouquin particulièrement
drôle mais tentant oui un peu peu de
distance un peu
d'humour un peu de l'économie mais bien
ça on se régalait beaucoup trop alors
vous avez tout un tas de rituel depuis
quand vous arrivez dans une chambre
d'hôtel vous disposez des photos de lui
sur le bureau sur la télé sur la table
de nuit me dire qu'en faites vous ce qui
est extraordinaire dans cette histoire
c'est que vous ça doit vous faire
souffrir mais ça vous fait moins
souffrir de continuer à mettre ses
photos que de pâles maîtres apparemment
c'est à la fois une douleur est un
bonheur sir je supporterai pas de
remettre le couvercle se faire dénoncer
sans parler de voir depuis faire les
choses de plus de plus je suis très pour
le rip il ya un autre rituel qui est
incroyable c'est que chaque mois dans la
nuit du 12 au 13 vous veillez jusqu à
3h19 qui est l'heure de sa mort et vous
envoyez à ce moment-là 3h19 des textos
oui à ma fille et à la mère de ferdinand
et pour votre enfant c'est pas terrible
ce culte de l'enfant mort faisait pas la
fine on est très très solidaire là
dessus oui on est très on est très pour
le rite on est très pour la
commémoration
les traits pour le pour le souvenir pour
l'existence qui perdure malgré le malgré
que physiquement ils soient plus là jean
utilement plus là alors vous avez un
autre rite aussi jeté des fleurs à
l'endroit où l'accident a eu lieu oui
tout vous êtes sensible aux petits
signes c'est à dire que si la fleur
tombent au bon endroit ben je me dis
qu'il faut il faut pourquoi ne pas le
faire enfin pourquoi je vais bien j'ai
envie de j'ai envie de le faire aussi
bien
si je ne faisais pas je serai je me
sente encore plus malheureux
oui oumalou coupable ou non faire du
nord il avait 20 ans il est mort il faut
ça vous aide je fais pas ça pour que
jamais de je fais ça pour faire du nom
alors il ya des trucs de fou c'est à
vous pensez à un moment à ralentir les
cigarettes pour rester en bonne santé et
pour que continue à vivre ce qu'il y a
un an vous de ferdinand dire si je meurs
ferdinand existera - j'ai décidé un
petit peu de ralentis parce que je me
dis si je suis fumic j'attrape une
saloperie que je meurs c'est pas c'est
pas bien pour ferdinand au moins ça au
moins ça qui continue c'est un petit peu
à travers un tout petit peu à travers
moi alors voulu laisser des messages sur
sa boîte vocale vous avez peur d'en
laisser trop ce que vous dites la boîte
vocale va être saturé
jusqu'au jour où orange vous dit le
numéro n'est plus attribué bah oui nous
aussi on devrait le savoir ben oui c'est
là c'est la loi c'est le règlement
alors dites-moi quand même ce jour là
ferdinand avait quand même pas mal
picolé - triglia qui conduisait mais
n'avait pas mal picolé il buvait
beaucoup dire que comme tous les gamins
de les ados les jeunes adultes qui sont
les défoncer à quand ils sortent
jusqu'au bout pour sortir il avait
besoin d'une dose et avec se
retrouvaient et continuer
nos limites ouais mais vous lui disiez
vous il faut pas que tu piccolo temps on
aurait bien sûr
alors vous dites là la morve me fait
plus peur c'est à dire que j'étais super
hypocondriaque et où j'ai toujours peur
d'avoir des trucs et tout est là dans
seul coup vous prenez des choses avec
eux
peur de la mort est là
bien [ __ ] quoi en tout cas c'est pas
moi mon fils mais
mais j'ai plus peur non plus qu'avant je
traîne contre il ya passé que la mort
vous a fait ce qu'elle pouvait vous
faire de pire en fait oui ouais ouais
donc je suis relativement dégagée par
massa alors voilà vous avez fait une
association donc
beigbeder vous a trouvé un très beau
slogan à moustoir les reste vivant amusé
sur le budget ouais c'est bien dans une
association qui lutte contre la conduite
en état alcoolisé chéché jeunes de faire
des films là dessus qu'ils aient de
dévaloriser l'image du type qui conduit
bourg et dire qu'en fait le ringard
c'est plus lui qui voilà ce qui ne boit
pas c'est celui qui boit voilà qu'est ce
que compliqué à faire
[Applaudissements]
alors
il ya eu un procès
le conducteur de la voiture a pris trois
ans dont 6 mois ferme vous lui en
voulait aux gars
je
oui et non je
n'en sais rien parfois oui j'ai jamais
une grande colère j'ai eues
dans le bouquin vous avez des mots voilà
connard c'est pas terrible c'est pas
très méchant non absolument sa colère
parce qu'il n'est pas à la hauteur jeudi
qu'il devait pas aux teintes où il a pu
coller voilà mais c'est ce que vous
dites il a picolé il a pas maîtriser la
situation par maîtriser
solesmois moi je crois que conduire
bourré c'est pas un tabou tout le monde
le fait tout le monde l'a fait on
revient de soirée la restaurer je pense
que le jour dans les consciences dans
les esprits on se dira que conduire
bourré un peu allumé même un peu un peu
à peu pété c'est un tabou ça se fait pas
c'est grâce à une loi dure à ce mois on
aura gagné
donc c'était salut les terriens avec
patrick et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu